good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy tuesday
wow it's only tuesday yeah that didn't
feel good saying it that's tough stuff
that's tough stuff but we're here to
brighten and enlighten you for today's
morning toast we have a really fun
episode of the toast today we've much to
discuss and you know things are shifting
like we are a very structured organized
show but we are shifting we're making
some changes after recently making a
rather large uh globally impactful
change for moving deer toasters on
wednesdays to tuesdays
this week again we've decided to move it
back to wednesday we have a really big
show today and i just don't want today's
episode to be like eight hours and then
tomorrow's to be 30 minutes it's nice to
spread it out it is nice to spread it
out so we have the fast dive stories
today and i think they're going to be
fast i do i know and do you think
they're going to be five
just about just about okay just about
five cool then we have to recap bachelor
in paradise because we did what we said
we were gonna do and we watched and i
i didn't hate it oh i did i have a lot
of thoughts kind of so i'm excited to
talk to you about it and it was nice to
see the gang back together and the beach
and i think it came out better than i
thought it was going to me too but my
expectations were so low that it's still
not great yeah i feel that so we'll dive
into that in the tv recap dear toasters
is being pushed to tomorrow i'm sorry to
the dt stands the dts and then we have
such an exciting guest joining us
ben saffer i don't know if you guys have
ever heard of him but he's quite a small
indie like artist he's caught his
husband
and he is the ceo of the company spritz
society which launches today so he is
here answering all your questions yeah
and he did say that this is the society
season two he said that he said it and
you know what like we've been
posting on social like a little bit here
and there just you know secret project
secret project secret project but today
it's just a project it's not a secret
because it's our latest project ben is
the ceo of sprit society's gonna tell us
all about it cause i know you guys have
a lot of questions and it's very
exciting we're very proud that today is
the launch day we have a big lunch party
tonight and i've been vlogging for the
past week the whole launch experience
launch week um you know drama with the
with the website like oh you know all
this stuff you know the tea
so you're gonna share that blog on
patreon yes so it'll probably hopefully
be up by the end of the week um
and so it's very exciting so we just
have like a lot of things to do today
business to attack yeah so we should get
right into it just wanna let everyone
know it's back to being freezing in the
studio i'm so
happy hence the blanket for me but also
because your legs are so tan and
stunning thank you and mine literally
pale in comparison literally and so for
a multitude of reasons it's a blanket
day for me plus it matches my outfit so
it just looks like a little skirt i
finally like i don't know why i got
really into like a
groove of doing my own spray tan which
is fulfilling in some ways but really
nothing compares to a professional doing
it and i had totally forgotten like how
much better it is and i'm just like
feeling myself you know it's the best
feeling in the world you offered if i
wanted to come and do it with you and i
was just like too [ __ ] lazy and i
should have done it yeah you should
because now i'm leading a life of regret
so i'm just gonna have to be putting on
like body makeup for tonight yeah no
when i got my lip wax my eyebrows like
i'm [ __ ] snatch right now i have a
day like that today a day of spa
services i can't tell you how i'm
dreading it it's such a like once you're
done with the day of spa services and
it's not like spa like you know facial
it's spa like getting your labias ripped
out like it's really [ __ ] painful
so it's not like a spa day it's a ch
it's chores it's chores it's the
chores of the physical body and i'm
really not looking forward to it but
looking at you i'm looking forward to
the end result right like this is what
you could look like right this is i'm
the before and she's that and you know
so funny it's like after all those
maintenance appointments you don't even
look different but you feel so different
that it exudes this radiance from within
even though like
you showing up today and you show up
tomorrow to me no i can't see a
difference no and the thing the services
i'm having done like they're you guys
actually can't even see them i'd be
better off just like getting a spray tan
and remaining hairy totally totally
um
okay so good luck with that thanks big
busy day we have due here to get us
through the day another day another
brewless day another day another do
another day another due another day
another dollar another no brew brew is
coming this week i i can promise you
that you need to give me heads up
because like i was walking into the
building today being like did jackie say
she was gonna bring brew like i can't
remember like you didn't say anything
but like you were supposed to bring it
on monday so i thought maybe it would
fall to tuesday and then i was like oh
my god [ __ ] it's gonna be ben
theo bruno spritz like it's gonna be too
much yeah no i
i will get bruce stuff together his
calendar is just really crazy oh i'm so
sorry i have a present for you
for me yes oh my gosh so in the present
saga i'm like oh for 11. jackie's except
i did get her gucci bag a while ago and
like that pretty much beats all the
gifts but jackie's always like seeing
things and thinking i'm just always
thinking of you and i saw something and
you know before i give it to you let me
just shout out because it's a toaster
own business oh okay and i want her to
know that a her package has been
received i'm so excited she's gonna see
this so i don't know
yeah i just want to also shout out her
business just give me a second oh okay
like can you oh madison crowley photo
okay photo okay cool and i framed it for
you too
ready you show the cameras first close
your eyes i mean i think i saw like when
you pulled it up
it's a watercolor
painting of do and brew in a stunning
frame these are my boys those are your
boys
dew and brew isn't that so cute name a
more iconic duo did you see name a more
iconic dew oh and by the way she wrote
on the bottom of the nibblings
i'm dead knowles is going to plot where
are you going to put it um right next to
my bed totally next to my bible nose is
going to plot nose is going to parts
i don't even think about normal i know
obviously obviously another madison
crowley photo this is just so stunning
thank you so much did you get tagged in
that like watercolor on it i thought it
was beyond stunning she really captured
the essence of doing brew no it's so
good
and it's just stunning i actually wish i
got one for myself no and like she just
could have written underneath we them
boys
making noise yeah i that was my fault i
should have given her more artistic
direction no that's okay i'll just
always read
and they're always making noise so
thank you for this beautiful and i'm
glad to know because i was actually
getting really worried the gift that i
got for you is not at all this and for a
second i thought we got each other the
same gift well because like i dm'd the
girl after i saw the watercolor i'm like
how can i buy like a print and she we we
purchased it and i was like maybe jackie
thought the exact same thing like it's
not that far but i feel like she would
have told me yeah yeah no oh my god that
would be really funny no mine is totally
in a totally different vein and i'm
feeling really good about the constant
gift exchange me too i think it's such a
good
pattern for the show me too just like
little knickknacks and like and it's
like a little competition like who's
thinking of the other more yeah you know
it's probably you but like don't don't
count me out no and i even if just you
know once in a while it's it feels so
good to be thought of it does so thank
you claudia a pleasure and now i have my
boys ugh and you know what they're doing
they're making noise
all right
okay let's dive in
without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite of your morning toast
i'm laughing because we were actually
doing like a lot of a dude like you know
how it's usually without further ado
to do like we were talking about the
dues right before so it was like really
with further ado yeah yeah so um today's
episode is funny
i have a job to do oh i'm laughing
today's episode is brought to you by
orate a fine jewelry brand founded by
women for women where their pieces range
from classic to statement to completely
original or a makes the jewelry you've
always wanted but can never find their
gold is super substantial and their
diamonds sparkle and shine they're super
high quality and really really beautiful
and that's because it's all real gold
you can wear it never take it off in the
shower you can play sports you can sleep
you can cook you can really do anything
with it because orate is jewelry for
life and all of their pieces come with a
lifetime warranty because they know that
it lasts they sell directly to you
without a middleman markup so they can
offer the same quality as traditional
fifth avenue brands but it's all at a
fraction of the cost because they've
really hacked the jewelry market and
they're making real gold accessible it's
all ethically sourced and sustainably
made their gold is never mined and they
also give back and support various
causes ranging from the environment to
social causes empowering women youth and
children
it's founded on the desire to shake up
the jewelry market and it's designed by
women for women and now you can play
with pay with klarna which is a really
big deal because besides transparent
pricing all right has now teamed up with
klarna to make their items even more
accessible you can shop now pay overtime
and it's just a more flexible way to get
what you want from orate so it's you
know as part of being an adult is like
investing in good jewelry that you don't
have to like recycle every month because
it turns your neck green and orate's a
great place to do that the pieces are
stunning and they're all so well made
and now that they offer klarna it's much
more accessible so if you want fifteen
percent off your first or rate purchase
go to oratenework.com
toast15 and use the promo code toast15
that's orate new york a-u-r-a-t-e
newyork.com
toast one five
toast 15 is the code at oratenework.com
toast15 thank you claudia are you ready
for our first story
it's a pleasure
pete davidson has split from bridgeton's
phoebe viner after a whirlwind romance
they say distance made it hard this one
they you know what goes up must come
down yeah and it was time i guess even
though i thought we this had more of a
i didn't shelf life pete davidson is
like just like you know the hottest man
in hollywood he's just like slinging
around at some point the cycle has to
break so with every
seemingly happy relationship for him i'm
like this is going to be the one this is
where pete you know he can't look back
after this i guess but i think i
remember when this news broke um i was
doing podcast episodes and i was doing
it with taylor strecker and we were like
going on and on about like why we hated
this um and i just like hated it because
like i don't know it's just not fair
like phoebe
gets to like [ __ ] bridgerton and like
make out with pete davidson and then
also like be in younger and like oh hey
hook up with josh it's just like save
some for the rest of the world you know
so i don't know i was kind of bitter
about it when you and i spoke about this
coupling like we were so over the moon
about it and overjoyed so it just sounds
like you're having different
conversations with different people i
don't really remember when we were
talking about wendell wimbledon and
we're just like there's two types of
couples and we were just like oh yeah we
were really like failing over these we
were yeah
i mean you probably said like you know
some girls really do like just
have it all well you know so but not
without like feeling so happy for like
this beautiful couple really yeah well
it's just so funny how like your
emotions can change because like when i
heard about them breaking up like i
literally didn't even care
i just like i really like them as a
couple they made a lot of sense i'm sure
like his next girlfriend will also like
be you know some skinny blonde skinny
blonde like just super relevant cool
person yeah well he's super relevant too
yay no but like every girl that he dates
is just like a star do you think you
can't like think about who he's gonna
date next thing i definitely wouldn't
pick like whoever he's gonna date next i
would never even think of that i'm like
she's not even famous yet like
right but then it will make so much
sense when it happens so he's like best
friends with machine gun kelly and like
machine gun kelly is like majorly settle
down with me gun do you think that like
that's inspiring him to like want to
settle down
no no neither i don't like nothing in
his life has changed like since all
these relationships have started you
know so i don't know what it's going to
take he's also still really young why
would he settle down um and he's at like
the height of his fame
yeah so he's just you know and maybe
he's really
looking for the one and he just hasn't
found her yet
interesting who do you think is the
right person for him ari
anna i really feel like it's carly
equally now
um no i think it's ariana grande and i
just don't think they gave it a fair
shot i actually think that at one point
i was like really much very much
thinking that her and pt him and pete
cazzy david and pete davidson like we're
the perfect couple no every girl that he
is with it is the perfect couple and
then it doesn't work out that's what i'm
trying to say maybe so the next one
person he dates is also going to be the
perfect couple maybe he's the perfect
man maybe he is the perfect man that's
true actually like everyone he's with
i'm like oh my god perfect yeah speaking
of everyone he's with segway to our next
story his ex-girlfriend margaret quality
remember jack antonoff spotted making
out with jack antonoff all over new york
city this is a this is pretty cute jacka
and off put his wild heart on display
with his apparent new gal pal margaret
quali over the weekend in new york city
the bleacher singer and margaret were
spotted out and about on saturday
leaving little doubt as to their couple
dumb with various acts of pda they were
seen stopping for ice cream at milk bar
where they embraced and kissed before
continuing on with their treats
um
i was wondering so i don't know if you
are too but she's 26 and he's 37.
oh because i thought she was younger
than that actually i don't know i never
i didn't even think about it i thought
she was like 18. so
she's old enough to make her own
decisions 100
um here's what i want to say about this
one i don't know why i still thought um
jack antonoff was with lord
yeah and like basically lord stolen the
dunham's boyfriend and it was like all
this taylor swift girl squad drama firm
that jack antonoff was with lord i think
so or it was just whispers no i think
it's like confirmed like they were seen
and spotted i'm pretty kissing and
things i'm pretty sure okay
so i just didn't know that we had moved
on from the lord era of his life now i
don't you know what's so interesting to
me about margaret quailly
is that like i don't know like famous
kids are usually as famous as their
parents like of course kyogre gerber is
the biggest model in the modeling
industry like look at her parents and
like andy mcdowell is i love her she's
in my favorite movie uh beauty shop
but
she's not like
that famous like you know what i mean so
like the fact that like margaret quailly
has become like a young hollywood
a-lister dating everyone like so under
the radar so cool like it just doesn't
match like the president i think
that's on her talent
telling us what an actress oh like she
was on in once upon a time in hollywood
she has yeah she she has all of these
like big like real serious acting things
coming up
and so yes i think when your parent is a
celebrity like some doors open for you
and like but i think the fact that she's
so successful and like so
such a serious in such serious pieces
like just speaks to her talent as an
actress oh that's really interesting
because i just was always confused i'm
like of course like famous kids are
always famous but their fame usually
matches their parents fame like very
rarely do you out
succeed your parents yeah no it's like
if she wanted to be in a movie in
hallmark like she could have easily run
that because you know andy mcdowell the
beach house you guys have to see it it's
so [ __ ] good any metabolic i just
want to say like
when i was a kid
i could not tell andy mcdowell and
charlotte york apart like to me they
were the same person okay okay fine i
also had that with sandra bullock and
julia roberts like to me they were the
same woman for the entire time i was
like on this earth i feel that um
but also she's a fabulous actress i just
want to say she is i want to look up her
did you see she embraced gray on the can
red carpet i did see she imagined a
trailblazer i did see that i just want
to look up what movie she's been in now
because andy mitchell yeah because i
feel like there are some really good
ones for me she's the most famous from
beauty shop with queen latifah the best
movie of all time she was in footloose
the remake
oh i never saw the remake with miles
teller and julian huff not that like he
wasn't they weren't the couple but they
were so good no
he was um the friend of the lead oh
right who like learns how to dance but
the remake of footloose is so good and
underrated i just want to say no i
actually think i have a list of movies i
need to watch because i was actually
asking ben last night he also has never
seen field of dreams which is weird
because ben like loves sports right so
that's on my list of movies to watch as
are both annie's and now
what does movie does all three annie's
no all two
there's three no victor garber and the
one before it
and the og yeah
wait quickly mm-hmm what was this movie
we were just talking about
andy mcdowell a footloose footloose
that's also that's going to be on my
list okay cool we need to bring back to
his movie of the week i know
okay i will get off andy mcdowell's fan
page
yeah okay so anyways margaret crawley
jack antonoff back to the two of them
i ship completely do you yes
this to me is like another couple that
just makes so much sense i would have
never i don't like i would have never
thought to put them together but they're
just so they seem so i mean i hope
simpatico
is radical
hypnotic i hope that she's a taylor
swift fan like i feel like that's a huge
part of being jack antonov's girlfriend
you know i'm sure that she is yeah
honestly like
i don't know if i like feel bad for jack
antonoff or like hate him because i do
you remember when he was dating lena
dunham which was like so crazy
that she wrote that article like guess
who said it my dog or my jewish
boyfriend like that was like so reeking
of anti-semitism and i was like oh my
god poor jack antonoff and then i'm also
like but it's like he's did you allow
that he's here by choice no totally and
it's like you probably thought it was
funny and told her it was good like so i
don't know if i like him or i hate him
because of that but
he's a good friend to taylor so we stand
yeah i i hear what you're saying i just
that's just one of those things in my
mind i'm like i can't believe like that
happened no no i don't wrote that
article i agree with you completely i
just feel like if he dated lena dunham
like he suffered
you know do you remember i was actually
thinking about this the other day do you
remember those years where like lena
dunham was the eighth girl of hollywood
the queen of the world like when those
four girls walk down to the emmys and
like the golden globes during award
season it was like the world stopped no
it was the craziest thing and like just
the fall
i mean it's impossible to go from that
to and not fall but boy did she have a
fall from right right where it's just
like
i think a lot of it was in her like a
part of her book that like people
started to dislike her right there was a
lot of stuff and i just i think
eventually
it just became too much too much yeah
anyways i'm ha i i'm happy for him
me too like this is cute you ship
yeah would you say that i don't really
like know margaret at all that's a thing
i just feel like i know her i know i
feel like you feel very like attached to
her in some ways
i do i
can you explain her i don't know i just
feel like i feel like she has like a
really bright career in front of her she
seems like a really nice girl
i feel like you're rooting for her
that's like the vibe i'm getting i'm
rooting for her we're all rooting for
her yeah yeah and she needed p davidson
so she clearly likes like funny quirky
guys and that's true she doesn't go for
like the obvious choice yeah she was
dating shyla buff
oh
yeah yeah yeah wait
i think i saw online somewhere like a
short film they did together they split
after fk twigs sued um him for sexual
battery assault and infliction of
emotional distress and then she later
expressed her support for fk tweaks over
instagram well i had seen this short
film they did together i totally forgot
about it until now because that like
honestly margaret cruelly was standing
right in front of me like i wouldn't
know who she is but somebody showed me
this movie
with her and shia
hmm
they were like naked and stuff it was
pretty good nice are you ready for our
next story which is a little more couple
news
a little more couple news yeah
christelle stouse and jason oppenheim
are continuing with their charade and
making their
red carpet couple debut at chang
chi premiere
honestly the height difference is so
real have you seen these pictures yes i
have of course um i don't know i'm kind
of here for
well she looks amazing the height
difference and like how they're just
embracing it like she's not wearing
heels he's not wearing like platforms he
is she is wearing heels that's what i
mean like she's she's not not wearing
heels because her boyfriend's short like
right
boyfriend
boss quote unquote um no acting partners
the height difference doesn't bother me
and i agree like i like when like a
couple just owns their height difference
and i like them each as individual
people i'm just again standing by what i
said that this is not a couple i don't
know what this is about maybe it's you
know
to drum up some buzz for the next season
of selling sunset like maybe they both
have like someone that they actually
like who they're trying to make jealous
you know so they're like let's marry
let's do this thing
and then like everyone will come running
you know no i agree it's such a weird
couple like they don't look like a
couple anywhere they go and now i've
seen like a couple pictures videos of
them where they both look so unnatural
and so uncomfortable around one another
and that's just not how you're supposed
to look with your new boyfriend like
you're supposed to like have the
butterflies honeymoon stage no and like
every picture where they're showing us
that they're a couple like trying to do
couple things
it's just so unnatural totally and
it shouldn't be that hard to convince us
no it shouldn't be that hard to just
like be around your boyfriend yeah it's
very bizarre but they're keeping the
charade alive i would love to hear what
christine has to say
we need to hear from christine i'm
really looking forward to the next
season
so am i it's been a long time when did
we start selling sunset in coven yeah a
year ago like september of last year
that was a fun time that was a good time
like it was still like two weeks to
flatten the curve like it was all so new
no it wasn't september of last year we
started flattening the curve in march
september yeah sorry sorry yeah no no it
was like two years to flatten the so why
was that a good time just just of
watching selling sunsets oh sorry yeah
sorry i misspoke yeah you did
are you ready for our next story only if
it's the next story that's brought to
you by
noom yes it is
you know when it comes to losing weight
there's a lot of pressure out there to
label foods as good or bad but that just
creates an unnecessary dilemma because
newman's here had a noom is here to
change how we see food with a psychology
based approach that looks at what you
eat but also how you eat and instead of
making you feel guilt or regret numa is
going to empower you to keep going
because not everyone wants to be on a
strict diet do two days at the gym or
drink strange teas noom's cognitive
cognitive behavioral approach helps you
unlearn bad habits and better understand
your relationship with food one size
does not fit all and that's why you can
choose your goals and noon will
personalize a weight loss program just
for you they want to help you and give
you the knowledge and wisdom to help
build a smarter more sustainable habits
eighty percent of new users finish the
program and over sixty percent have
stuck with their goals the first year
with noom taking care of your health is
empowering instead of stress inducing
there's no need to ruin your whole day
because you you know
had a little snack or you went a little
off noon is just gonna help you get back
on track all you need is a daily
10-minute check-in there's no grueling
early mornings or huge chunks out of
your day i know that you've had a lot of
success with name can you tell me what
you love about it jackie i love noob and
i've had a lot of success with noon
because for every stage of your journey
there is a program for you i've been
doing noom at times when i've wanted to
you know put in the work grind time
show me how to you know shred
to be the snatcher but also in times of
just like maintenance and wanting to
maintain a healthy lifestyle
but not having specific goals that i
want to achieve like noom just has a
plan for everything and i think those
success rates of 80 who finish it and 60
who keep their success within the first
year that says it all because i think
that that's what we're all striving for
start building better habits for
healthier long-term results sign up for
your trial at noom.com toast that's
n-o-o-m dot com slash toast
noom.com
toast
what do you have to lose
next story a little more legal news
about the girardies oh no what no tom
jardy's law firm is selling erica jane
collectibles to pay creditors amid
ongoing bankruptcy case oh i heard they
were having like an auction and they're
building but that includes america's
items yep and they're selling staplers
and everything but
something for the studio
totally erica jane is indirectly helping
her estranged husband tom jordan's law
firm pay off creditors i'm sure she's
vomiting over this of course gerardi
keys is auctioning off memorabilia from
the real housewives star singing career
amid the former couple and the firm's
ongoing bankruptcy case described as
erica jane collectibles there have been
25 bids placed on sign magazine covers
framed photos of erica and tom and the
billboard plaque for her 2009 track
roller coaster the memorabilia is
currently listed for 350
us weekly confirmed last month that
gerardi keys is selling quote the firm's
office furniture business machinery and
equipment as well as furnishings and
decorations comprised of art oriental
rugs sports memorabilia wine music
memorabilia maybe we need one of the
gerard keys oriental rugs for the studio
set like this this rug is getting dirty
maybe it's time statues vintage lawn
other books a vintage piano a cadillac
dts and much more what's about about
that cadillac we need a company car
totally wait this is so sad like that's
where they're at like selling their
staplers just to make ends meet to pay
their creditors and i'm sure erica of
course is vomiting like not only
according to her like her name has been
dragged through their mouth in this
whole situation now they're using like
her name and likeness to sell things
just to help them pay bills because they
are being sued for stealing money from
orphans and widows right and like it's
not even like she's benefiting
whatsoever from the sale of her items oh
and didn't you also send me another link
today about this that bravo has been
subpoenaed to fork over i just saw that
bravo has been subpoenaed yeah okay
nobody came up to you
hold on someone and i didn't see that
because last week we said that bravo was
probably going to willingly share unseen
footage with the courts and now you're
saying bravo has been subpoenaed okay
this is on reddit so i don't know if
this is legit but it's uh bravo served
with papers to preserve
and hand over all information and
unaired footage looks like sutton was
right to distance herself as the letter
would include all employees which
include housewives
whoa
and this is like a they have like this
law
this legal letter that was supposedly
given to bravo i don't know if this is
legit
whoa but that's crazy that is crazy
speaking of just housewives legal
matters have you seen the real
housewives of salt lake city of trump of
course it looks infuriating like jen is
maintaining her innocence blaming the
other women for her getting indicted
which is she's like blaming meredith for
working with the feds justice for
[ __ ] meredith okay and yeah like
honestly i love heather but it's like i
see her in the trailer like out to lunch
with jen being like i'm gonna be your
friend like by you by your side all this
and it's like
no yeah she wasn't you like she wasn't
even a good friend to you last year and
last year we didn't even know she was an
insane criminal right like now we know
that she's so corrupt the morally
corrupt gen cha and you're still going
to stand by like now you're going to be
friends with her when you just weren't
friends with her because she was a bad
friend right and now you have like the
most reason not to be friends with her
and you're going to ignore it i don't
know if that's i don't know if like
maybe that's an early scene when they
don't really know what she did like
we'll say it looks like lisa barlow is
taking some investigative matters into
her own hands in this season and trying
to get to the bottom of it at the
reunion last year she was being such a
kiss ass to jen it was so losery and i
bet when all that stuff came out lisa
barlow was like freaking out cause she's
like oh boy did i choose the wrong side
yeah so it will be interesting i mean it
obviously looks so good but it is a
little disappointing and i guess like we
have to wait to see the trial and you
know you're innocent until proven guilty
but when something is a federal case
they're not just like wasting your guilt
also um
we just stay standing meredith marks
like i just feel really good about my
decision last year to stand with her
because from the looks of the trailer it
looks like she will not disappoint ever
yeah
when when jen called her fraudulent
what no like how insane how up is down
down is up it looked like a really good
and i actually think like salt lake city
was always a good franchise but this
whole drama i do believe like will
catapult their ratings and just like
cement their space in housewives like i
feel like at any moment the house size
of dallas could get cancelled yeah i
feel you so i just feel like salt lake
city has already surpassed dallas in
that sense i agree with that in a weird
way yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which will lead into our tv recap
no i'm not i know the triangles have
been neglected all day
but it's finally time for the final
story
[Music]
[Music]
that was so beautiful i feel that peace
i do feel at peace as well
bachelor in paradise sets a record with
six couples hooking up including grocery
store joe bachelor paradise season seven
premiered featuring a whopping six
hookups including memorable memorable
appearances by queen victoria grocery
store joe and new host david spade okay
so this was gonna launch us into our tv
recap i guess it was a really slow day
for news that's exactly what happened
and i want to talk to the spritz king
himself so i watched the real no
the bachelor in paradise premiere and
it's been a long time since i watched a
show and i was definitely like going
into it really low expectations it was
better than i remembered um i do
i just have gotten used to the last
couple shows i've been watching so much
like too hot to handle are you the one
love island and they're like just actual
good shows
no take that back not too hot not too
hot to handle okay you're right yeah and
i actually feel like you have to handle
a similar to bachelor in paradise in the
sense that like so much of the footage
isn't nothing like it just takes so long
to move on from like a conversation and
i always i've forgotten because it's
been so long since i watched like how
they're just really relying on like
gimmicks and like
i'm a cat like
that [ __ ] is not funny like nobody
thinks that's funny this isn't a show
for children like we're all adults like
just get to the part where everyone's
like on the beach making out it's just
so annoying but having said that i do
think it's a pretty good cast there's a
lot of people like i really like like
i'm obsessed with kelsey from iowa like
i just love her and she looks like
honestly
her and david spade were having like a
real moment and i think david spade like
should meet someone i agree and i think
it should be kelsey i think it should be
two
i'm worried that kelsey is not going to
be around for a while because she wasn't
in a lot of the previews like she wasn't
in the like the the couple saying i love
you in the previews
she only had like three scenes and like
three outfits i feel like and she didn't
meet anyone the first night i feel like
she'll stay this week and then she'll
give her reals next week and then she
gets home sent home the next week and
that's just going to devastate me i was
thinking the same thing because honestly
like i don't really remember a season
where everything moved as fast as you
did the first night and like if you woke
up the first night and you didn't kiss
someone like you're 10 steps behind yeah
but some of the couples i really dig
like first of all grocery store joe like
is
i feel i don't really know him whatever
season he was on i did not watch that
girlfriend
kufron and by the way she's coming so
like that'll be interesting
yeah i know like she discarded him and
now it's like but then also when i
thought they brought in kendall i'm like
oh they're just playing with us now i
know i was feeling sad and they made it
seem like in the previous he falls in
love with ceramic and that he's leaving
her for kendall i don't believe that's
what's gonna happen but he did say that
he loves serena p yeah
by the way and i like them so much as a
couple he's very funny when he was like
talking about all the other guys like
are cool with their outfits and like he
just and he like swimming on from there
to get his hair cut it was so funny and
cute like i actually understand the why
people are obsessed with them like he's
a very cute his chicago like he's so
cute yeah hey and serena are an amazing
couple like i love how everyone was
after serena and i was kind of shipping
her and brendan from tasha season yeah
but brandon likes natasha i know and by
the way natasha was
so slept on in this franchise like she
deserves to win this whole competition
like she's i forgot like she's she ever
got to talk on her season like she's
hilarious and she looked gorgeous and i
actually really liked them as a couple
me too um even though like it's just
night one like and everything was gonna
do it looks like in the previews brendan
is like
with someone else i can't remember who
though yeah that's what it was feeling
like now
i do
people who come on like victoria like i
just hate like the goddess like it's
just can we grow up like this is a show
for adults like all these gimmicks it
bothers me so much with crabs like shut
up
yeah the goddess i like i think victoria
is coming on with a new energy which i
appreciate and i hope she gets along
with everyone but like all these like
props and [ __ ] and like these names just
like
leave it to us just be yourself i agree
be yourself and like she's looking great
like just give yourself a chance yeah no
one's gonna come like you're so
intimidating
creepily smiling at everyone for five
minutes like it's crazy yeah
um okay and then also abigail and noah
okay i'm also really glad noah's story
is being rewritten because i do feel
like he was
uh who's he who's auntie with bennett
yeah like that thing was so stupid and
like i actually really liked him and he
did come off like a little bit like a
dick because his mustache but like i
don't know i felt like i really liked
him and when he just came in like i want
abigail like i have worked with you know
so many deaf kids as a nurse and like i
just think she's amazing like she's my
hero
love and like
i'm just obsessed like they're a great
couple yeah um
yeah but i feel like what else happened
other couple like other there were other
people like
hooking up with that guy's uncle yeah
was everything i know but i like that
they're
into each other and i'd like i feel like
the last time she was on first of all
i've never related to someone so much in
my life like everyone finally is talking
about how hot it is like thank you and
it does look like it's hotter than ever
and i don't know i feel like she was
kind of made into like a joke when she
was on and that's like not nice and i
feel like she's being given like
somewhat of a serious edit like in the
sense that she's actually making out
with someone so i hope they don't like
make fun of her again i actually really
don't like that
let's talk about mari and kenny
and why is he nude even though i don't
believe he's not news i saw something on
tik tok like literally they had a black
box around his like genitals the entire
time and for one second they took it off
and he was wearing like a
blue bait polka dot bathing suit that
was like pulled up all the way like a
thong
no like it was shorts but he was like
wearing it as underwear like he pulled
it up that's so weird yeah like he was
not naked
what's wrong with them like why gimmicks
it's gimmicks so [ __ ] stupid so
[ __ ] stupid the only thing is so like
the ages of everyone are really
interesting 23 because we have like 23
year olds and we have 40 year old kenny
but we also like kelsey is 30. so
there's people all through like all
different ages
grocery store joe was like 30
yeah he's like 5 36 35 and
uh serena was the 23. yeah so it's like
if the 40 year olds are going for the 25
year olds what chance does a 30 year old
have totally that's such a fair point
and you're right like the age thing is
very weird and i actually really liked
mari on her season she was on me too on
matching seasons and i was really
surprised that she came in like gung-ho
for kenny i'm like ew really no a lot of
people were interested in meeting kenny
he's like the worst personality we
didn't get to know him but he just was
the boy band manager yeah and he was
like starting fighting i guess he is
handsome i just never like
i don't know
i just never thought about it he reminds
me of like that guy from
dukes of hazzard
he reminds me of kevin dillon from
entourage
who's that drama johnny drama that's
really funny they look exactly like yeah
i feel that um so all in all like it was
fine i was definitely losing interest as
the episode went on like they really
just know how to waste our time yeah um
and i didn't really get particularly
invested in anything so i definitely
could see myself falling off of this
show if it doesn't get better yeah um
and i just i don't know i was so happy
to be rid of the franchise like even
just like supporting them was really
like traumatizing for me but i do have
to say i think david spade actually did
an amazing job he was very funny um and
he he knew his place he's like no one
wants to hear what i have to say like
just cut to everyone else yeah and like
not every single person had to walk down
and talk to him like some people just
walked in without him it was just
refreshing because they waste so much
time giving us like nonsensical
content with chris harrison like just
dumb stuff yeah also i don't know why
this really bothers me every season that
it always starts with the guys having
the roses and i think it just always
puts the show kind of on the wrong foot
where the women like
just like like we saw last night like
the women have to go out of their way to
like court these men the men don't do
anything and they and they're proud
they're like we don't have to do
anything right and i just feel like it
always just kind of sets the wrong tone
where it always feels like the women are
competing and the men get to be so
[ __ ] lazy and i don't know why i
thought this season that i read
somewhere i don't maybe i had a dream
that the women were giving the roses
first
and i think that would have changed
a lot of the tone of the show in a
really positive way
and i'm just upset that that they keep
doing that that's actually if they're
important i didn't think about that
either because like they just come in
and like on and
the men should have to work harder than
the women like these women are so
[ __ ] stunning and perfect like put in
the work yeah i think as a whole like
the group of girls is better looking
than the group of men yeah but like it's
just it's i don't it's every single
season at least [ __ ] switch off
totally every other year totally it
really bothers me i could tell it does
um so that's that's your paradise recap
right anything else
no
no that's all i watched i almost watched
siesta key but then i got distracted but
um have you been seeing the reports that
juliet and sam broke up yeah yes i have
seen it
how are you feeling i feel really badly
about it i'm i'm kind of in denial and
feeling like maybe it's you know for
show or something
but i'm feeling really really like if
it's if it's true and it's long last and
it's not over and it's not coming back
i don't know what's going to happen well
i want to let you know like we are all
here for you i know when i saw the news
i immediately of course thought of you
so
i'm sorry and we're going to get through
it and you know what maybe maybe it's
not a goodbye maybe it's to see you
later okay but like what could have
happened they were so strong i don't
know
maybe like with all they've been the
show re-airing
like if they could go through all the
stuff that they went through on the show
and they were fine what could have
happened off air no but maybe like when
it re-airs and like so many people you
know seeing it and talking about it like
it brings up it can't be easy it can't
be easy but i'm talking about both of
them i'm sorry thank you thank you for
your support um i'm excited to bring out
our guest because he's been sitting here
while we do the entire show and he looks
bored so
um
ben come join us and our guest segment
is brought to you by glamnetic where the
last struggle is real
from
finding the perfect lash for your eye
shape to a grueling application process
it's exhausting and frustrating and
that's why glamnetic has put in the work
to craft beautiful lashes for every
shape and they've made the application
way way easier it can be done in seconds
all you have to do is take their quiz to
find the perfect lash for your unique
eye shape and style get you can get rid
of lash glue for good because with
clemenetic it's the world's first six
magnet lash made for easy application in
all day hold they have sold over 500 000
pairs of lashes and so we hopped on the
train and had to try them out for
himself for ourselves i've been trying
to get into lashes forever and i'm just
i just can't do it like i it's
impossible um but with clamnetic they
take under a minute to apply it has no
toxic glue and no struggle and you can
reuse the lashes up to 60 times they're
eco-friendly and wallet-friendly and
they offer over 75 styles for your
perfect fit from natural to glam and you
can get a different lash for every mood
and occasion they have over 500 000
happy customers and 100 money back
guarantee and expedited shipping with
free shipping to the us and canada on
orders over
thirty dollars
find out for yourself why glamnetic
lashes are instagram's favorite beauty
hack go to glamnetic.com toast and enter
our promo code toast for 30 off your
order this code's only available for our
listeners at glamnetic.com toast and the
promo code is toast at 30 uh 30 off at
checkout check it out you you won't be
disappointed get glam with clarinetic
guys it's the sickening it's sickening
okay hi ben hi
oh hello ladies wait
no of course no i had to get one out no
i'm sitting there by myself i couldn't
do it
no
right time for you to do it is right
when you got in front of a microphone
that's a perfect time yeah no that's a
really good idea
how'd you do that
i love that idea
hi how are you did you guys see that
theo just migrated over we did yeah
we're attached at the hip he wanted to
be with mom and pops how am i i'm
wonderful
can you talk into your mind you're also
on a podcast
oh my god
let me adjust it would you prefer for me
to sit back i've never sat so far over
you know without any pillows behind me
yeah i don't know if you guys are
sponsored by any like arthritis company
do you want a pillow uh like one
immediately take one maybe like one of
the four pillows yeah i use four you can
take two i have one you could have one
of mine too oh wow jackie that's so
generous of you okay let's see oh wow
it makes it different like in the couch
now
okay are you feeling better much better
yes okay so ben is here we're super
excited today's a really big day it's um
august 17th a day we've been waiting for
for a really long time because we have
all launched a new company and it
launches today it's called sports
society and i think a lot of people have
been seeing like little treats we've
been leaving on instagram but are
confused like what is a company whose
company is it what's inside these boxes
so can you give us your little elevator
pitch
okay
spritz society
is your new favorite canned cocktail
there are many questions i don't want to
answer like too many of them like i
don't like divulge too much before you
ask questions but
we are wine based
sparkling cocktails we come in four
delicious flavors grapefruit pineapple
lemonade blood orange my favorites
lemonade a lot of people's favorites is
grapefruit don't write off the lemonade
it's delicious my favorite is lemonade
ben what's your favorite flavor
definitely definitely the grapefruit i i
love the grapefruit all of them we're
not going to show you right now
but all of them when you pour them out
or this gorgeous color that's
representative of the box so everything
that you love about other spritzes you
go to a restaurant you know they're very
instagramable like pretty pink like you
know what i mean all the stuff that
you're missing from like those gross
hard seltzers to be honest with you well
so let's talk about that because i think
a lot of people assumed that this was a
hard sell sir can you tell everyone what
the base is and why you decided not to
do a hard sell sir aside from obvious
reasons because there's like a thousand
okay so first they're wine
wine based so
if you've had a bellini if you've had an
apparel spritz if you've had anything
like that it's closer to that than it is
to a seltzer but still a totally
different taste profile hopefully you
guys agree yeah they're so so good
not too sweet not too dense they're
really drinkable and they're something
that i i really love to drink like
that's why we did this i
transparently don't like hard seltzer i
never liked hard seltzer it reminded me
of like drinking a lacroix or drinking a
pellegrino like it it smells like lemon
but it doesn't taste like anything well
i also think that for me like my journey
i fell in love with heart seltzers
during the pandemic and then i grew some
sort of like what would you call it not
like an allergy but like an intolerance
to it you started to become various they
made me incredibly sick for days and i
never had realized i just assumed that
like a white claw was like a vodka
but it's not it's malt so a lot of all
these a lot of these seltzers their base
is not an actual alcohol it's malt which
it's just like
doesn't agree with me and i've heard
that a lot of people it doesn't agree
with so that's why i was even more
excited about this because i was like
missing out on the canned cocktail like
fun that everyone was having because i
can't drink seltzers and now these are
so good and transparency was incredibly
important to us like we you guys every
single day come on the show and you're
as authentic as humanly possible
everything that we do has always been
very authentic and transparent and to
your point you were drinking hard
seltzer for two years and you didn't
even know what was in it like it's great
like zero carbs zero calories whatever
it is but or a hundred calories uh zero
calories
two calories
but you don't know what's in it there
are like five ingredients on the back of
this yeah it's incredibly incredibly
clean
delicious all natural all natural very
very fruity we've got the fruits that's
what you said we have
okay so let's talk a little bit about
the process because
first of all how long has this been in
the making
um
about 17 months
and like of course you've never launched
an alcohol company before so where do
you start like what's the was it harder
than you expected i've never launched
any company before one quick thing for
the last eight years everybody's been
asking me what is your job and first of
all go on [ __ ] google it's on
linkedin like it's you look at my name
like it always blew my mind that people
can't just google yeah well if you're
not like invading your privacy they're
actually respecting
i actually think that's quite lovely
okay whatever
if you didn't google and you didn't know
previously i've been in advertising and
now my full-time job is spritz society
spritz season
and bringing this company to life so
would you say
that in this moment it is spritz season
such a good question ben
anything it's definitely
spritzes hey
and so
we're launching today 3 p.m eastern time
oh of course we have a code for the
toasters i just have to put that out
there so it's spritsociety.com and if
you go to spritsociety.com
toast you get the variety pack for 20
off so that's one of each flavor there's
four cans in each little pack um but now
i want to take some questions from the
instagram if that's okay with you of
course
um spreadsociety.com 3pm spritz
society.com
toast if you want to get the code but
yeah spritsociety.com
but i just want to make sure it's spritz
s-p-r-i-t-z
society s-o-c-i-e-t-y
dot
c-o-m
slash
toast yeah we know that o-a-s-t
and you get twenty percent off the
variety pack you really don't want
anything but the variety package you
gotta try all you got you gotta try all
of them because then you're like oh [ __ ]
i love grapefruit give me a hundred of
them yeah so i would definitely
recommend trying the variety pack you
won't know what your favorite is until
you try all of them okay first question
a lot of people know if you're going to
be releasing merch because the they're
commending you on the branding being
sickening uh merch will be dropping
probably sometime in the next two weeks
we wanted to to have another moment you
know like this moment is for the cans
cans in hands you know
beautiful cans and then and then the
next moment will be merch nice so yes
for sure do you mind if i pop one of
these openings of course yeah
um
are they carbonated yes where are they
made like where's the wine from people
want to know uh california specifically
sonoma
and where can people buy it like
can everyone get it it's being shipped
nationwide but there's about six states
that aren't allowed to ship wine
directly too
i'll tell you what they are it's
available exclusively on
spritzsociety.com
over time we will be in wholesale
markets but for right now but if you
live in
utahsociety.com if you live in utah
arkansas rhode island delaware what's ms
missouri mississippi mississippi
what's ms
like the state and us i'm voting
missouri i think it's missouri
let me just google there are five states
by the way they know if you know you
know you've never received alcohol
before because your state doesn't allow
it so as long as you're it's mississippi
wow nice work
okay that's funny i think
um whatever utah arkansas mississippi
rhode island delaware unfortunately your
states do not allow us to ship wine to
you but everywhere else you can get it
correct um
sorry let me find more questions for you
oh if theo bruno and magnolia were each
a flavor which would they be that's such
a good question can i take a stab at it
yeah sure okay i think that
magnolia would be grapefruit because
she's
she's a little sour i think i like hard
disagree with that but okay grapefruit
is not sour no but like the the flavor
of a grapefruit it has that aftertaste
and that's like knolls like she'll love
you and you'll love her first she's sour
then she's sweet even though she's sweet
then she's sour okay then i think that
theo is blood orange because he's the
original oh
god i couldn't disagree more actually i
agree with that he's orange is like our
traditional flavor yeah and i think that
brew is pineapple because he is just a
good time i feel that am i what are you
god
okay
crunch is grapefruit because he's the
favorite of the bunch but everybody has
a different favorite no that's true
great so then this is my list okay
i will give brew the pineapple because
he certainly is a good time thank you
and i will give magnolia the lemonade
because
she doesn't miss a party i really like
this question because i feel like it's
something you kind of raised by but
someone was like i'm one of those people
that's really annoying about food
allergies are the ingredients on the
cans of slash packaging
every single ingredients on the
packaging yeah you know you don't have
to like legally so it's really [ __ ] up
i was just about to say if you go and
pick up any other canned wine
or canned beverage you'll see some of
them do not have nutritional facts on
the back
because legally you do not need to put
them on the back we intentionally were
transparent because there's nothing
worse than needing to search the
underbelly of a website to find out like
how many calories no it's true like and
the fact that you don't even like
legally have to put it on like made no
sense no sense yeah but yes it's all
right here also abv
six percent great question most seltzers
in the four to five percent some are
even lower it had to be high it had to
be high because
look we're we're here to have a very
nice time elevated drink but in the end
of the day you want to have a nice buzz
yeah you want to feel good about
yourself but you want to enjoy your way
to the buzz for sure and i think that's
really important yes like we're not just
drinking to drink we're enjoying the
experience and they're just delicious
because of how good they are yeah um
sorry i'm just
people are asking a lot of the same
questions like where can i buy them oh
good question
what is the difference between keto
season and spritz season
spritz season is okay to season heated
season is
the world in which we all live in all
the good times everything is just key to
season so today the launch of spritz
society spritz season is key to season
okay somebody had another good question
why don't you call it spritz season as
opposed to sprite society because spritz
season is something that all of you know
because you've heard me say it but when
this shows up
in a store and somebody's like what is
spritzes
like nobody people not everybody knows
what that is it's like it's a nice thing
for us to like talk about like it's
spritz season but you guys the truth is
spritz society
is
is us like the society i knew how many
fights we got into over the name like
over the last year like you would die
yeah it was a lot it was a lot but
spritz society makes the most sense
because it's what oh yeah claudia and i
had we were obsessed with like one
claudia and i had some really good name
really good names but you know what at
the end of the day the best name one the
best name agreed agreed i'm not i'm not
bitter that's name one do you mind if i
talk about the name for a second sure
please
so spritz society the word society could
be off-putting to some
it's a very inclusive society not if you
watch the society okay okay good no it's
the society is deep roots in this show
yeah okay good i don't know the show um
by the way when i was sitting over there
and you guys are recapping i have no
[ __ ] clue what you're talking about
in paradise yeah i i just i don't watch
no it's good
save yourself save yourself no don't
worry save yourself
um but so spritz society is really just
it's us you know it's it's the toast
it's the bunge it's the grunge it's the
swange
it's
it's everyone it's the brilliant
it's the crew yeah it's it's it's
everyone it's a society of people that
are are like
people we want to hang out with totally
great fun vibes
yep forever so i think one more thing a
lot of people wanted to know is like
what do you like it's like you want to
start a company like this like where do
you go like where do you start so what
were like the three big things you had
to do
to get this off the ground obviously
like fundraising okay the first thing is
you assemble a team of people that are
smarter than you so i'm i'm good
at what i'm good at i'm not good at what
i'm not good at like don't think that i
just
like ran randomly was like
starting a liquor company like i needed
people that had experience starting
liquor companies so it's one team is
incredibly incredibly important and i
would be nowhere without the team that i
built
uh
what was the second question what else
do you have to do like oh yeah okay so
you built you build a team you go out
and you raise money ideally you raise
money from people that can sort of help
move your business we call those
strategic strategic investors you may
know them as sharks yes exactly exactly
yes from sharks
um
and then from there you start to
wow where do i even begin find cans
uh design logos design packaging there's
actually a group i don't know how many
of you toasters were in the we're in the
original spritz society but i sent out
a google form to 3 500 people asking
their opinions on logos flavors can
designs abv so really some of you may be
partook in creating this
um
but yeah it's just it's a step-by-step
process
uh one could describe it as building the
plane while it's crashing
in the hopes that it sort of soars again
um you're looking at me strange did i
say that wrong maybe it's building the
plane while i'm flying it better
probably oh yeah it's going down like if
it crashes then at the place i like the
amalgam i thought it was you know what i
was saying yeah
i think it's stressful is what i meant
and like we're gonna make sure that it's
not true you could have just said that
okay whatever it's stressful uh insert
analogy so yeah just lots of steps
and the biggest one right now is today
yeah lunch 3 p.m
spritzsociety.com
toast forever 20
okay also this is just kind of like a
more kind of deep question so
how much was bruno paid for the cameo in
uh if you haven't if you don't follow
spritz on instagram which you should at
spritz we did this sickening like
lifestyle video in la and bruno was
literally the star like all these models
bruno stole the show oh yeah wait can we
can we quickly talk about the handle
spritz sickness that's sexy there's any
questions asking how you got that
username
and i don't think you should tell it is
what it is it's what it is uh was bruno
paid for his cameo he was we put it in a
fund
um bruno's college it's tucked away
that's smart uh i just didn't want him
to spend it all in one place i agree his
mom has like some crazy spending habits
so like maybe he would have bought like
an lv leash and like blown it all like
we we need we need him to save it we
need to like think about his future we
do need to think about his future but
brew had an amazing time on set the cast
and the crew were so good to him and of
course you know he stole the show he
wasn't fun fact he wasn't even meant to
you know be the star but he wasn't even
supposed to be in it like he just ran in
right now and everyone like wanted to
meet brew and they're like oh my gosh
and then he gets into the into the frame
and he shines
and so you know what we call that
talent talent and so as his mom i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna dim his his shine
i'm not and the girls loved him
everybody loved him ladies man he was a
ladies man he's definitely a ladies man
and like he just knew the perfect time
to start licking you know yeah
like he just like right in frame a
couple of licks up
oh it's
so
a masterpiece the final question for you
was
as a self-proclaimed keto king which
flavor pairs best with this sushi
i think grapefruit personally pairs best
with with everything but i do want to
like be very clear
all of these are so [ __ ] good i've
actually they're so so good
i've heard most people's favorite is
actually pineapple pineapple i love also
but i just want to say do not sleep on
the lemonade it's so good and the orange
too i just they're really great i've
always just loved grapefruit in general
i think it's just a wonderful fruit
um can i actually have a box i just want
to show them sort of what it jackie sort
of did it before but i don't know if you
can see this in frame i don't know what
frame i'm looking look at that camera
okay look at that camera okay
spritz society
gorgeous
look at this it's beautiful pattern work
isn't it but this is a podcast so just
make it quick oh true true okay so for
the people that are listening we're
looking at a beautiful box and if you
were watching the video you'd know what
it looked like but you can go to at
spritz on instagram to see them or you
can order at spritsociety.com
wait let me just show them the cans
quickly so
open from the side also
very easy to hold transport trying to go
to a friend's house go golfing you can
slip it in your bag
yeah they three fit in my golf bag
i'm just saying you can't do that with a
12 pack open the side oh that's true
gorgeous and this is what this sexy item
looks like you can have them over ice
pop them in the fridge they're best
no they're best enjoyed chilled oh yeah
nobody that's honestly we have to write
it everywhere which
i've been thinking about it like do
people ever not refrigerate products but
if you don't sometimes in a pinch but
it's not ideal yeah like a warm beverage
is terrible so for the ideal first
experience when you receive your order
i would just pop them in the fridge
maybe an ice bucket
make sure they're cold for sure at
spritsociety.com
toast to get the toaster approved
discount just for the toaster community
ben we're so proud of you we are so
proud of you it's been a long road we've
been waiting for this day for a long
time and it is here we're so excited to
share it with all of you and for you
guys to all try what we've been enjoying
and so excited about for so long and
it's so nice to take the secret off of
project yes oh my god it's just a
project it's just a project at
spritsociety.com toast i think you guys
are really going to love it ben great
job we're proud of you we love you we we
appreciate you guys too you know this
really is a team a team effort
we really hope everyone just enjoys it
like check it out i think it's really
the perfect beverage for
your lifestyle for everything and we're
just really proud so check it out and
anything else you want to shove in there
before we go no that's really it just
just check it out enjoy it with anyone i
we've tested this amongst millennials
boomers whatever's older than boomers
are they still alive yeah of course
older than boomers
yeah they are yeah yeah okay every one
of those x y z's etc yeah they'll all
love this so try it share it and let us
know what you think yes please thank you
so much for listening to the morning
toast the morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i heard
radio cast box all the places so every
listen to podcasts find out morning
toast leave a five star review about our
beautiful stunning and smart we are and
for the society season two i think
fruits leave a bevy of fruits on the
morning toast instagram to know let us
know you're part of the society on the
sprint's instagram too pineapple also if
you want to at spritz in the comments
that would also work okay also um that's
not how you start this yeah
you don't understand the society
everyone have a great day we'll see you
tomorrow bye
you